the skeletons of deception island's
brutal past still scatter its beach
a hundred years ago it was one of the
most important whaling stations in
antarctica
the rusting pressure cookers turned
thousands of tons of blubber into lamp
oil
but the onshore stations couldn't
compete with the arrival of industrial
factory ships able to butcher and
process whales out at sea it allowed the
fleets to plunder the oceans with brutal
efficiency with catastrophic
consequences for antarctica's giants
now scientists are trying to piece
together the impact of the slaughter on
the whole ecosystem these are columns of
mud lifted from the antarctic seabed
they contained dna signatures of life in
the sea at the time
and the deeper in the mud they're buried
the further back they go its
environmental history
a lot of the baleen whales are eating
krill
suddenly there's fewer whales a smaller
whale population so that's going to have
immediate impacts on the krill the
zooplankton and there'll be knock-on
effects right the way through the
ecosystem and so we want to see if we
can detect those changes
before whaling starts to see what the
situation was before whaling started
two years on and the scientists are back
in their university labs trawling
through the dna signatures
so far they've found marine life in one
antarctic fjord crashed 30 to 40 years
ago for as yet unknown reasons and as
they go back further in time they should
see the impact of whaling
the fact that we have um
a significant change which has obviously
occurred at a particular point in time
is a heartening result it's showing that
we are
in in a
in a
very sort of broad brush kind of way we
are able to reconstruct something
meaningful about about the the ocean
system
since commercial whaling stopped in the
1980s the population of some antarctic
species has begun to increase but no one
knows how many whales there should be
by reconstructing a healthy ocean
scientists will have a better idea
whether marine conservation is anywhere
near ambitious enough
thomas more sky news